supongamos que además de es igual a cero
cuál de estas expresiones es equivalente
a a por b y como siempre te invito a que
pongas pausa el vídeo para que lo
intentes de hecho estos me parecen
problemas bastante divertidos entonces
bueno veamos si podemos resolverlo
hagamos algunas manipulaciones
algebraicas en la ecuación entonces
sabemos que a más b es igual a cero si
restamos vez de ambos lados obtenemos
que a es igual a menos b pero entonces a
que es igual a por b
absorbe eso puedo yo escribirlo de
varias maneras lo que puedo hacer es
sustituir la a con la ve negativa porque
sabemos que a es igual a menos b y en
este caso a por b será igual a menos b
por b que es igual a menos b al cuadrado
otra opción sería como a es igual a
menos b
entonces yo puedo decir que ve es igual
a menos a simplemente estoy
multiplicando a ambos lados de esta
igualdad por menos uno entonces b es
igual a menos a así que en lugar de
sustituir a a puedo sustituir a b con
menos a y esta expresión quedará a x
menos a que es igual a menos al cuadrado
ahora veamos cuál de estas dos formas es
una de las opciones que tenemos para
elegir aquí está ve al cuadrado pero
observa que no es negativa no es menos b
al cuadrado pero si está menos al
cuadrado entonces me voy con esta opción
menos al cuadrado